Use the commutative law of
addition-- let me underline
that-- the commutative law
of addition to write the
expression 5 plus 8 plus 5
in a different way and
then find the sum.
Now, this commutative law of
addition sounds like a very
fancy thing, but all it means
is if you're just adding a
bunch of numbers, it doesn't
matter what order you add the
numbers in.
So we could add it as
5 plus 8 plus 5.
We could order it as
5 plus 5 plus 8.
We could order it
8 plus 5 plus 5.
These are all going to add up
to the same things, and it
makes sense.
If I have 5 of something and
then I add 8 more and then I
add 5 more, I'm going to get
the same thing as if I had
took 5 of something, then added
the 5, then added the 8.
You could try all
of these out.
You'll get the same thing.
Now, they say in a different
way, and then find the sum.
The easiest one to find the sum
of-- actually, let's do
all of them.
But the easiest one, just
because a lot of people
immediately know that 5 plus 5
is 10, is to maybe start with
the 5 plus 5.
So if you have 5 plus
5, that's 10, plus
8 is equal to 18.
Now, let's verify that these two
are the same exact thing.
Up here, 5 plus 8 is 13.
13 plus 5 is also 18.
That is also 18.
If we go down here,
8 plus 5 is 13.
13 plus 5 is also equal to 18.
So no matter how you do it and
no matter what order you do it
in-- and that's the commutative
law of addition.
It sounds very fancy, but it
just means that order doesn't
matter if you're adding
a bunch of things.